[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Chris is
and spok in Washington hey Chris welcome
to the ramsy
show hi guys how are you better than I
deserve what's
up um so I made the mistake of getting
into a house with my ex fiance um and I
just yeah I just don't know where to go
from
there um she we were in the house for
about 7 months and then she decided to
pull the plug on us and I'm just kind of
confused and don't know where to go and
how to handle
it wow you're a case study and why we
tell people not to buy stuff with people
they're not married to yet oh I'm so
sorry
Chris yeah oh man you got a heartbreak
and you got a pain in the butt both huh
yeah how long ago was the
breakup uh about three months ago who's
living in the the house um I moved out
recently and she's staying in the house
right
now have we discussed when we are going
to sell our
house um we have discussed it and we've
actually talked to a realtor about
putting it on the market but she would
only walk away with about two grand
which I was okay with but she wasn't up
for just getting rid of or just getting
back to two
grand
sorry right don't care that's what I
told her don't care what you want you
broke up we are selling this
house get it on the market if she won't
do that you're going to have to hire an
attorney and force her
to okay and that was I was kind of going
that route to see if I could hire
somebody to get her on board to do that
no I think you call her and go sit down
and say look I really want to do this
the easy way there's an easy way and a
hard way but we have to get rid of this
house this house is we are not together
in the future and we are not owning a
house together in the future we are
getting rid of the house now do you want
to put the house on the market and let's
do this nice or are we going to have to
get
ugly okay I sit down in person with her
have a very calm conversation don't
bring up all the past don't bring up all
your heartache and your broke and
everything it's a simple conversation
about we are selling the house that we
own together because we aren't together
anymore and we are doing that now are
you on board with doing that because if
you're not this is going to get nasty
and I don't want to be
nasty right and it's been pretty nasty
already so yeah yeah and so you know I
would sit down and say that like this is
the last chance okay and then if she
doesn't if she says okay I'll put it on
the market and then she doesn't send her
a letter certified mail return receipt
requested so you have proof that the
letter was delivered and saying you have
10 days to get this house on the market
or I'm going to be in touch with an
attorney and we are going to escalate
this discussion it's going to get really
expensive
right because dude this is not going to
go well if this drags out five years you
understand that right
yes and that's why I've been that's why
I wanted to call yeah who's paying the
mortgage uh we we're splitting it and
you don't live there no this is a
problem right and that's why I needed to
talk to somebody because I have so many
people in my life giving me different
types of advice and I listen to your
guys' show quite a bit and I figured I'd
call it some more advice yeah how old
are you
guys um I'm 30 and she's 27 okay and
you've uh were in the house together for
seven years or seven months how how long
have you were you dating before all that
five years
wow so that's why it's kind of confusing
and kind of heartbreak and yeah oh yeah
it doesn't make any sense at all I agree
I'm with you yeah right are you going to
walk away with $2,000 as well or is it
not an even
split yeah it'd be about it'd be about
2,000 some change each which I'm okay
with doing that but she didn't seem to
be okay with that yeah well she doesn't
have to be okay with it I mean this is a
stupid tax that we to pay what is her
suggestion um well she we did want to
list it and then she said no because she
would only be walking away with the two
so she wants to keep it and then try to
put it on the market for after two years
because then we wouldn't have to pay
income tax as you pay Equity into a
house that there's not any income tax if
you make $4,000
right the income tax is 400
bucks yeah that's what's going through
her head so see that's dumb show her how
math works and maybe that will help
speed this up oh God cuz we're not going
to ride this out for two years as you
continue to pay a mortgage and build
equity yeah maybe yeah this we know we
we did not buy a rental property
together for us to run together that you
live in no you you broke the marriage up
and so we're selling the house ready set
go if we lose $2,000 a piece we're
selling the
house right so this is not this is not
an investment that we
maximize yeah that was another thing I
told her it's going to cost us to sell
this house too yeah you're both going to
have to pay a stupid tax here and it
sucks yeah this is our yeah wow I'm
sorry Chris sorry you're facing this but
yeah you need to you being passive in
this situation instead of proactive is
not going to work so I I would sit down
I've had a lot of um good things happen
in Conflict scenarios when I can sit
down in person with someone it changes
the tone keep your voice real low and
calm and just say this is not going to
work we've got to get out of this you
broke my heart I can't stay in this with
you we're not going to own this house
together we're going to put the house on
the market this week and if you don't do
that you're going to force me to become
ugly and nasty about this and I really
don't want to I just want to get away
from this situation completely and now
and just real calm like that in person
hopefully you can talk some Senter or
that way without trying to do this but
really you I really don't bring up all
the old stuff all we're dealing with is
a single issue get the house sold that's
all you deal with don't don't don't
overlay all the problems and the fights
and the other stuff in the relationship
with this just are the things that you
don't like about her none of that okay
even if she escalates you stay calm just
go look one thing one thing we're
talking about the house one thing all we
got to do is get rid of the house and
then you got rid of me and until you get
rid of the house you're not going to get
rid of me and it's going to get ugly
don't want to do that please don't make
me create your free every dooll budget
today
the simplest way to budget for your life